i gave up my house i gave up my car i
put everything in storage
i lived on tour i never bought anything
for years and these are the types of
things that i think when you believe in
yourself and you believe in something
if you build it they will come basically
[Music]
melody thornton it is so nice to see
your huge smile it is
the joy and the energy that we need in
the world right now
you have given us the gift of lioness
eyes how does it feel that your baby is
finally out in the world
oh my god my child has gone to college
you know like
there's been tears of joy there have
been moments where i'm like oh my god
you know just so overwhelmed i'm an
independent artist
yes so um i'm self-funded and i've
kind of had to make some really serious
sacrifices so i'm really really really
really happy
of course we we got to know you with the
global success of the group the pussycat
dolls
but now you're a solo artist so i'm
curious
who is melody my music is inspired by
the late 60s early 70s
cher and donna summer edie gourmet and
jose jose
like other yeah other artists that are
known very well in the latin
community my dad's african-american so
he's like
bb king is life you know you have to
listen this is real music
so um i'm a combination of all those
things each song is kind of it's like a
it's like a tailored suit
you know there is a difference even
though there's this huge argument
over like why can't i just buy a pair of
jeans from you know so
yeah you're more than welcome to the
reason why a tom ford suit is a tom ford
suit is because it's been
you know it's the cut it's the design um
it's supposed to fit you a certain way
and so
i kind of like to think of myself as
like a curator designer for
myself um all of the music is
exactly what i would say the way that i
would say it loads of passion
and soul i come from a world that was
very much like this is what you're gonna
sing and this is what you're gonna say
and this is
you know this is who you're gonna be
pink had a hard time coming out of that
fighting her way through that christina
aguilera same thing you know and it's
like they had to release these projects
that were so
left of what you know people knew them
for or were
or were coming to know them for you know
before you end up
even further down this rabbit hole i've
got to be honest with you
this is who i am this whole project is
you through and through you executive
produce
you write you sing tell me what else are
you involved in are you doing hair and
makeup are you responsible for the looks
that you are serving in these videos i'm
not even gonna lie i look forward to the
day when i can be like cool somebody
else come in and do the wardrobe
yeah i do the wardrobe i do i did the
hair for pretty much
every video um had help with makeup
every now and then but yeah it's
when you're independent you just try and
get the best bang for your buck but also
you want it to look
the way that you always envisioned that
it would look
you know if i am the artist and creator
let me create you know let me be like
trust me um
why wouldn't you coming from the major
label background and now being
independent
how do you feel are there things that
you miss about having
uh the backing of a major label or is
this the the
arena that you see yourself staying in
for me
at the moment just so that i can
continue to
make you know change direction if i want
to and
make a video about blm and and talk
about you know my experiences
through my art i want to be able to do
that without it being a huge argument
you know like oh let's not get involved
you know if if i'm passionate about it
i'm gonna get into it
[Music]
your first single phoenix rise you chose
to spotlight the black lives matter
movement and really shine a light on
social injustice
why was that important to you as an
artist you must speak to the times
that's just how i feel the first video
was not meant to be phoenix rise it was
supposed to be another song
and we shifted gears and it's this
parallel between 1968
and today and how they kind of look the
same
so the video was black and white for
that reason you know to kind of provoke
thought around
like yo this is we're still going
through this
you know yeah i think it's so important
to you know spotlight
black stories and talk about um what it
means to be
a black woman in music so i'm curious
what has your experience
being a black woman in music what has it
been like
getting into the group i was really
conscious of the way that
society puts black women in boxes you
know
using stereotypes to describe black
women and i'm coming into this situation
the one black and brown girl
in a mostly you know in a group of
mostly caucasian women i was really
conscious to smile
in every picture that i was
every time i was photographed with the
girls and i
did that because and i hope that she
doesn't take offense to this but before
the pussycat dolls were the spice girl
the one thing that stood out to me was
why why why the black girl got to be
scary
you know like i did not want to be scary
doll
like i don't want to be annabelle that's
not you know that's not a good so i was
really
conscious to smile as often as possible
and hope that people
would get to know me before these
preconceived notions
you know there were moments in the
beginning where i'd be like
hello like i need a black makeup artist
you know i need someone who can
who can do my face are you not given
that
no no it was it was um
pick some people and let's go you know
and
i understand not wanting to make anybody
else feel
that i was being treated with favoritism
but that's not what that's not what's
going on
you know you need you need makeup
artists that understand
this skin tone they're not gonna make it
ashy you know
um being sent to different hair people
and
i mean eventually all my hair just fell
out you know
[Music]
you just dropped the video for love will
return very different from phoenix rise
it's dreamy
and soulful tell me about this song and
and how much it means to you
i want it to be a little middle eastern
but i want it to definitely be latin
my musical influences are shirley bassey
and nancy sinatra
and especially for this project you know
eartha kit i wanted to exude this
this sexuality without being overtly
sexual
and to have it read sonically and what
does that sound like so
it's a combination what life experiences
did you have to go through
to be able to write songs as personal
and poetic as
the ones on the ep when people say oh my
god i love pray for me i'm like i was so
depressed
finding my way out of a rabbit hole you
know
um being okay starting over
after the bar had been set so high
from this mega group you know
and and knowing that like it's okay
it should be okay for you to explore
different sounds and and being knocked
down over and over again
look i'm down right now but i promise
you i'll be back like i just have to
you know get through this um
and uh yeah i mean heartbroken for sure
big old thank you to the guy who broke
my heart because people love the song
i've always
but i meant every word and and the song
means something different to me now
um it's not i will wait for you but i
will wait for the right one
lots of ups and downs and just crawling
crawling
out of dark places um
yeah to the light and i feel good do you
have a favorite lyric
on the project i'm not running with a
butterfly net
um i loved i love
the idea of that and that's and that's
from the song love will return
what i'm saying is that i'm not
interested
in catching just any butterfly you know
i want
a specific beautiful butterfly that is
right for me
and i think it's you so come on home
god where the where is your perfect
butterfly he's got to be out there
somewhere
oh maybe i don't know i've been you know
i spent the last three years in the uk
in different parts of five months in
mainland china
and like different parts of europe and i
was like where
i feel like charlotte from sex in the
city i've been dating since i'm 15.
where is he
he'll come he'll come and i and i so
applaud you for
having that mentality because you are a
queen in every sense of the word and a
queen doesn't settle she waits for her
king and that's that
i i do want to ask because you are an
independent artist
and it's all you fronting everything
here what kind of sacrifices
have you had to personally make in order
to bring lioness
eyes to life the thing is i'm a very
blessed person so i don't want
this to be like a you know a mini violin
situation
but i definitely you know i gave up my
house i gave up my car i put everything
in storage i lived on tour
i never bought anything for years
um i would say six to three like three
to six years
of just like being away from family
missed every christmas probably for the
last three years
and you just lived based on whatever
project you were working on i know you
were down in australia for a minute
yeah yeah yeah i mean
what went through your mind like was
that is that nerve-wracking
not having a home base yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a different bed
every single night i would stay with my
best friend
in between trips so like three weeks at
a time i'd
you know sleep on his couch and then get
back out on the road and this went on
for years
um but it's okay like these are the
types of things that you
go through if you commit to i'm gonna
fund this properly i'm gonna give it
everything i've got
and and i hope that people will support
it as well just you know
in that story alone but i have friends
and family
and i will always have a place to go
for sure um but they knew they knew how
committed
i was to like i'm gonna go for this i'm
gonna really go for it
so all you made all these sacrifices and
all the while
just you watch the bank account just
kind of go up up up up up like
it paid off i have to imagine yeah and i
didn't even look at the bank account i
was like don't even think about it
sister
you know like this is this is not for a
vacation
or uh new clothes or anything no no no
no
no no i hope that that that can inspire
people to especially around this
pandemic like live
live today go for it make a plan of
action for the
the life that you want so you've got
lioness
eyes the ep's out now congratulations
you just signed with icm
so you know some big things are going to
be happening soon i'm curious what your
your top three goals are um as this
solo melody the artist project continues
to thrive
i would love to be in a movie for sure
i'd love to get one of these songs
in a movie as well whether i'm in that
movie or not i would absolutely love to
tour this project
some of my favorite artists um
in the 90s like you you'd hear a song on
their project
and then once you perf you saw them
perform it live you're like
oh i was iffy about that song until like
now i love it
my dad surprised me with janet jackson
tickets and it's like i always you know
i always liked the song but now